this red brick house in a Copenhagen
suburb dates from 1915 with her update
nearly a century later interior designer
Leila Elsa Horniman
transformed the former clinic into an
inviting family home I would like to
show you how we live welcome inside
follow me coughs deploying a nuanced
palette of grey with defining accents of
black the designer created a space that
is at once serene and dramatic for Lena
Elsa Horniman color is more than a
decorative element it's emotional colors
is very important that it takes you like
an inner journey it reminds you of
places and it gives you imaginations of
storage where you want to be or what you
would like to and that's why there's no
white colors here in this house only the
ceilings is why
despite the use of steely gray hues the
rooms exude warmth light is key in
creating that effect large new windows
were put in to let daylight stream deep
into the house the fireplace is the
heart of the living area and lamps both
designer and flea market vines create a
sense of coziness on long winter
evenings I was trying to achieve the
feeling in the house of I mean this is a
place you wanna be you only have the
second you only have this moment and if
you have to feel what is the best way
the best place to be I wanted to create
that not for myself by myself because I
don't live here by myself I wanted to
create that for my family
Hahnemann lives here with her husband
two children and three dogs the kitchen
is where the entire family comes
together
the designer has built a career on
designing kitchen islands for clients
she wanted our own kitchen to be as
beautiful as it is functional it's a
kitchen but it's not just a kitchen it's
more than that
because it granted here the table top is
brushed so it has like a softness it's
not polished and shiny it's more soft in
the surface and it goes really well
together with the cabinet's where you
have made of wood and it goes from one
drawers with the other drawer and when
you push the drawer it comes out and
it's electronic so it's practical it's
beautiful but it's also functional the
house boasts 400 square meters on three
floors but despite its rambling size it
maintains an intimate air space is
important to the ornaments and they use
every inch of it
[Music]
your house is your castle and you you
surround your things surround yourself
for things that you enjoy and you make
it cozy
you know the Danish word for here which
is coziness so I think that's a big part
of the Danish culture we still bring a
lot of friends and families back to our
homes so we have to open up our homes
and maybe that's why we really consider
how we live with with beautiful things
not only beautiful things like shapes
but also good quality they need people
like good quality and that makes it a
little bit more fun this isn't the first
house that Lena house a Hanuman has
bought and renovated for her family but
given how comfortably they've settled in
it may be a while before they move out
of this gloriously gray home
you